Kameron you are here at the Saturn
Awards you know yeah everyone it was sad
to see Krypton go away in your tweets
people have been really feeling it
supporting you what's the experience now
you take away from the show in your mind
I mean I couldn't be luckier really you
know for all of it that that show it was
family that all the cast and the crew
they you know the show might be over but
that friendship isn't over
you know what going forward there are so
many happy memories to take from it and
creatively we made something really cool
and we're so proud of what we did and
you know we left the fans wanting more
and obviously you you want to finish the
story you want a chance to finish the
story but that's not a bad place to
leave to leave things either and you
know our great hope is that you know in
the years to come more and more people
will come and discover Krypton and be
like you know this was a really cool
show and they did they got it right and
there's nothing but but pride and
gratitude that I feel from that exhibit
maybe somehow an older version of you
down the road coming back to do a
Krypton would be very interesting you
never know if they would they want me to
do it I'd happily do it as a geek now
you stepping into this world how
exciting is this night for you you know
it's great it's it's so fun it's
wonderful to be here and then see all
these people with many of whom are
heroes of mine and and you know it's sad
that Krypton is over but now the joy is
I get to just sit back and be a fan
again and I've missed that just purely
watching it for the joy of it all and
and really really happy to be and
nothing to spoil now because you don't
have to worry about that you can really
relax that open conversation absolutely
and you know and finally you know it's
all out in the open we can we can talk
about comic books and movies and this
stuff that we love well everybody
Collider loves you man what do you got
what do you got going on next you know
yet are you taking a break for a little
bit then figuring out what your next
step there are things happening but I
can't say just yet some really really
cool things but keep an eye open I think
I heard MCU I think I heard him say
thanks guys thanks Cameron appreciate it
good seeing you man